thank you so much ted silver state
schools credit union the sponsors of
this next segment wants to celebrate
their 70th anniversary with a very
special offer this month only check it
out
hi i'm scott arkiels president and ceo
of silver state schools credit union and
today we're here at our water street
branch in downtown henderson
one of the things that i'm asked about
or what are the benefits of membership
with a credit union versus a bank well
at silver state schools credit union
we're a not-for-profit member-owned
organization as a member you are an
owner and you benefit from great rates
on loans and credit cards specifically
we prioritize people over profit it's
not just a slogan everything that we do
is driven by our members one thing that
people assume is that you have to be a
teacher to become a member we're built
on providing solutions to our amazing
education community however we have all
kinds of members from different
professions as a long time partner with
vegas pbs we make it easy for anyone to
become a member with a small donation to
vegas pbs regardless of your profession
for 70 years we've been providing
financial solutions and guidance for our
members and we are celebrating our 70th
anniversary with a special offer now
through the end of october visit one of
any of our 10 branches around the valley
and enter to win a 70-inch tv
there's no obligation so come and visit
us talk to one of our fabulous member
service representatives and get to know
more about our credit union and then you
can enter and win a great prize while
you're there
thank you to silver state schools credit
union for sponsoring this segment give
them a call for more information
702-733-8820 and as you can see they
have a very exciting special offer enter
to win a 70-inch tv for their 70th
anniversary just see a member service
rep to join the contest we'll be right
back